I love someone like Darren Aronofsky who
really swings for the fences and creates
conversation how much fun is that for
you as an actor when everyone has their
own interpretations of your work in this
casing mother is very obvious that there
are many messages going across and
affecting the audience and that's what I
think it's brave on Darren's take which
is that hide that level he wants to
really share these issues that he's
concerned or interested about openly
with the audience in a way that he knows
that he's gonna be criticized for many
and also we are lucky liked by others
and that's brave and I wanted to be a
part of that we made the movie for
people to argue about it we thought the
argument would be more like I hate it I
love it but it's it's fun to see here
people's different interpretations it's
interesting because it's not that never
really occurred to us while we're making
it the allegory is so specific yeah
metaphors were so specific we want
people to take as much as they can from
the movie it started off with a very
very simple home invasion genre film you
know I wanted to return to horror once
again after doing Black Swan and I
thought everyone can relate to the fear
of people coming into your house and
taking things and never leaving we've
all had those guests sometimes their
family members who won't get the heck
out so turning that into a nightmare I
thought was something people could
relate to god help you but then there
was this larger idea going on for me
which was you know talking about our
home our planet you know not talking
about your mother or my mother but
talking about our mother the mother who
has given us all life and all of this
bounty to share and to take care of and
to make a film from her perspective on
what it must feel like when all of these
uninvited guests came in and our
taking from her so it kind of works on
two levels there's this you know husband
and wife with a marriage which is
starting to crumble as well as this
bigger metaphor going on and out of that
I think there's a lot of different
things people can see and for wherever
you're coming to the theater you're
going to get something different
[Applause]